[Music]
that would flow it's a tool to help
automate conversations typically it
could be used for three main groups of
use cases it could be businesses that
want to talk to their customers and
helping automate those conversations it
could be around customer service or
commerce the the second is powering
connected devices so this could be
connected cars connected TVs and being
able to intelligently talk to the people
that want to use those devices and the
third is connecting employees to their
to their employers and accessing
information business intelligence we're
going to focus most of today on the
first set but a lot of those tools are
going to be available and are going to
be useful for the second and third group
of use cases as well so you know the
space is super exciting you know we just
chose like four different statistics to
highlight here there's of course much
more you know 80% of customer
interactions could be resolved with with
well-designed BOTS that's that's you
know mind-boggling statistic if you know
if it actually kind of sees itself out
my favorite are the two on the bottom so
if you look at the bottom left a lot of
a lot of businesses today come to start
using BOTS to reduce costs so they can
serve users and their customers more
efficiently but actually in surveys the
interesting thing is customers actually
prefer self-serve tools when they're
asked what companies can do to improve
customer service sixty percent say that
self-serve tools is you know it's kind
of the biggest thing that they can do
and so you know there's like all these
customers that are kind of clamoring for
better self-serve tools but they're
forced to be
you know talking to agents for simple
tasks that you know don't really justify
agents and that last one fifty percent
of enterprises will spend more on pots
than traditional mobile development
that's also mind boggling if it actually
becomes true by 2021 so with all of that
excitement the kind of problem is today
most of the virtual agents that are out
there are not very good if you google
white chat box why chat box fail is the
top result of Josefa
right it's pretty crazy and why is that
so here on the left you can see an
example you know there's all of these
bots that were built kind of at the peak
of the hype a lot of companies didn't
really invest in building them out
properly they're not very intelligent
and it results in conversations that are
broken the good news is we think with
dialogue flow there's a really great
opportunity to build BOTS that are
intelligent and so the way it typically
works in terms of architecture what we
see customers deploying there's all
these channels on the left so it could
be text channels chat on the web
Facebook Messenger Google assistant or
it could be digital voice in a mobile
app in a car in a TV or phone calls
through a phone gateway they come to
dialogue flow which does the
conversation management and the natural
language understanding basically to
break down what is the intent and the
entities in that natural language and
then dialogue flow sends that structured
information to the fulfillment layer you
know we think Google Cloud is a great
place to host that fulfillment player it
can be on cloud functions or compute
engine but you could also host it
anywhere else you could put it on Prem
or wherever you want how many people
here in the audience were in the session
about dialog flow last year in Google
cloud next okay a few of you so a Google
cloud next last year in our session I
announced that we crossed 150 thousand
developers for dialogue flow so this
morning we just
announced that when there's now over
600,000 developers on the dollar floor
platform which is crazy right this isn't
just over a year we crossed that
landmark so it's not only growing it's
it's it's accelerating and and and we're
very very excited about the momentum and
then when we ask developers why they
choose dalla for because there are a lot
of other solutions out there for about
development today so it's a very
exciting space the answer we hear time
and time again it's not the bells and
whistles other other solutions out there
in the market have things that look good
on paper but at the end of the day the
most important thing that we hear most
often from developers is it's just the
quality of the natural language the
quality of the natural language
understanding and machine learning that
dialogue for users is ahead of shoulders
above anything else that's out there and
and it really makes a difference right
because what you want to do is you want
to avoid things like that right and so
it's much more important than anything
else you could want in a bot platform so
the exciting thing is most of that is
due to the natural language technology
that came from the API Tatia acquisition
that we didn't year and a half ago and
and so what makes us really really
excited is that we're we're just
starting the journey of making dialogue
flow better and now that it's part of
Google you know we we at Google have
actually been solving this problem of
natural language understanding for more
than a decade in things like Google
search Google assistant Gmail smart
reply
translation and we've built all these
assets and capabilities like natural
language understanding engines speech
recognition GPUs and all of these are
now available to download flow to build
better tools and so some of these
announcements you're going to hear about
today are basically a result of this new
Google technology becoming available so
you know putting together this slide
kind of hammers the point
you know it just for me personally I
just realized how much we've done and in
the last year it's pretty crazy if you
look at all of the different launches
and feature enhancements since our
session here last year at Google cloud
next 17 we've added so much the product
from built-in analytics to
multi-language support inline code
editor
you know stackdriver integration
versioning and lots more and today you
know we're excited to announce five new
features that make dialog flow really
well suited to power the enterprise
contact center so what we've heard from
a lot of you are there are a few things
that are still difficult to manage in in
chat box conversations the first is
connecting box to phones so we're going
to talk a little bit more about that
today we're going to make it much easier
to connect to phones
second is answering questions that touch
the long tail building intents is time
consuming knowledge connectors are here
to help with that third is automatic
spell correction so as you guys know in
chats users often make typos and and
mistakes this uses google technology to
solve that built-in sentiment analysis
we're introducing today that helps you
understand when you want to transition
to human agents and last but not least
built-in text-to-speech that also powers
our phone gateway and it's built on
wavenet technology so i'll soon through
these slides pretty quickly so we can go
to the demo and i'll show you guys how
some of these actually look so a Google
phone gateway is built on the same
technology used by project find Google
Voice and Google Hangouts
it already powers over 20 million phone
numbers today so it's already operating
at scale now it's available to any
dollar full user you can add a phone
number to your agent and
than a minute and the beauty of it wraps
all of the technology needed to make
phone automated phone calls happen
including speech recognition natural
language understanding speech synthesis
orchestration it's all handled by google
cloud knowledge connectors we're going
to go deeper in the demo so I'm gonna
skip that spelling correction so this is
it looks pretty easy but it's really
really hard if we had to build something
that helps automate spelling correction
for BOTS for dialogue flow it would have
taken us years and years to create
something that's reasonably good and
even then you know it's hard to get it
right luckily because Dalek flow is not
part of Google we were able to use some
of the tools that Google uses for other
products like search and I'm sure you
guys have all used spelling correction
insertion in other places and now da
fukken can take advantage of the same
capabilities and this applies both to
intense like you can see here on the
right and two entities like you can see
in the middle so built-in sentiment
analysis a very common concern customers
have is okay I created a bot but how do
I ensure there's a great end user
experience built-in sentiment analysis
lets you identify what the query score
is for every query that the user sends
and then you can use that in your
business logic to decide when you want
to switch to human agents and and last
but not least text suspect is speech
powered by deep minds wavenet gives you
the closest to human speech that is
possible for a bot and it's built in
both in our phone gateway but also into
dialogue flow so you can use it for IOT
and other uses the one other cool thing
that we just announced this morning
is we we also added device profiles so
what it does is we actually shape the
waveform differently for a speech
synthesis depending on which speaker you
use so if you play it on a phone line
will produce speech that's optimized for
phone if you play it on a large speaker
will produce speech
that's suited for a large speaker okay
so let's try and see how this all looks
like in a demo so those of you that were
in the session last year you'll remember
what we did was we built on stage here
or actually in Moscone the about that
handles chats for an imaginary Google
hardware store and it has an entity
called products like chromecast Google
home Google picks all things like that
and then it has intense one for service
one for commerce so if we look at the
one for commerce for example it requires
product address and quantity and so if I
say I'd like to buy chromecast's you can
see it identifies action is by hey the
product is chromecast but there's no
quantity and no address and now it asks
what address would you like me to ship
it to I can say three third streets and
Friends California how many units do you
want five units and then it's done it's
ordering five chromecast shipping to
three third Street San Francisco
California and there's a full JSON
I think this window it's not it's not
showing okay there it is there's a full
JSON you can use in your fulfillment
layer to act on it so what I'm going to
do now is what if you wanted to not just
help people buy stuff but also answer
questions people have about Google
products so let's look for a chromecast
FAQ webpage and we're just gonna choose
the first result that's here let's take
this URL and copy it over and let's add
it as a knowledge connector so we need
to create a knowledge base let's call it
my
knowledgebase and let's create a
knowledge item we call it store FAQ this
is going to be HTML it's gonna be an FAQ
and I'm gonna paste in the URL here and
what it's doing now it's going to this
URL it's downloading this article or FAQ
and it's going through the questions and
sorting them out there it just finished
so I'll show you guys the detail in a
second but it basically extracted the
information and then the next thing we
want to do is add a response so the
default response here is knowledge
answer 1 what happens many times with a
fake use though is the customer is going
to ask a question
you may not have the exact same
questions in the FAQ you may have
something similar and there actually
might be more than one there might be
two or three that are similar so what
we'll do is we'll copy it over let's
let's choose Facebook messenger for
example if a user is on facebook
Messenger they have the ability to see
more than one option so what we'll do is
what we'll we'll add cards in a carousel
here that show two different answers and
we'll we'll use question 1 here and here
it will be question to an answer to so
we're going to show them both the
question we match them with as well as
the answer so they know they know what
we wanted okay I'm going to click Save
and now just so you guys see the full
detail you can see this is what we
scanned from that website all the
questions and all the answers they're
all here and you can even disable some
of them if you don't want to cover them
in your BOTS okay so let's go back
well we'll try it out in a minute but
one other thing I wanted to show you
guys is our new phone gateway so you can
see this is a new square we just added
this morning the dialogue flow phone
gateway and what it does it lets you add
a new phone line to your agent in
seconds so all I need to do I click the
dial phone gateway and now I choose an
area code if I want to I could also
leave this blank but let's say I want to
choose Ohio I click Next now I choose
one of these numbers I click create and
that's done so we now have a phone
number in this agent and it always
starts from the welcome intent so we'll
go to the Welcome intent in a second
let's first test our knowledge
connectors so if for example let's say
there's there's a question here how is
this different from Apple's AirPlay so
let's try this question in Dollar flow
and let's see if it works
needs a minute to update
different from airplay
okay there it is so you can see it gives
the same this it retrieves this whole
answer from from the article even even
though the words I used are a little
different from from the article so I
didn't use the same words for the
question it knows how to match it now it
it looks very easy and for humans this
is a very easy task there was a view in
the audience that have done a little bit
of natural language understanding they
know it's it's um it's actually pretty
hard for a computer to understand how to
match things like that in natural
language because things sound very
similar when you look at it
programmatically so let's look at it in
facebook messenger and let's try now
there's two different questions here
about remote controls do I need a
separate remote control for volume and
other things can you use chromecast with
a physical remote control if I ask how
do remote controls work it could be
matched to either one of those questions
so it needs to update
try that
okay so you can see and matches to both
of those questions so I detects that
both of them work now this is this is
really really hard because remember this
is the same agent we're using that also
has the bot technology so if I say you
know I'd like to buy a chromecast it it
needs to both handle the Commerce
actions that we gave it as well as their
fake use I know when to use each of them
so it's it's it's none it's non-trivial
and there's a lot of kind of natural
language work that's happening behind
the scenes so let's see it all coming
together in our phone demo so this is
the phone number I'm just gonna try it
out now speech recognition demos are
always risky so bear with me here
hopefully this is gonna work I'm gonna
try it on speakerphone which is not the
best but let's see okay so if this works
what it should be doing it should be
going to our welcome intent and then
reading what we have in the welcome
intent let's try
to the dialogue flow phone demo how can
I help you today
you can order new Google products or
request service on existing one what's
the difference between chromecast and
Apple airplane airplay works by beaming
the video or audio directly from an iOS
device to the television over Wi-Fi
everything you're hearing right now is
not typed into that or anything it was
like jested automatically from a random
article that someone wrote on the
Internet
[Applause]
for beaming the actual content let's see
if the regular internist along answer
yeah can I buy a few Google pixels three
seventh Street New York New York
seven
so I just want to emphasize all of that
look looked really simple to set up and
we were able to do it in less than a
minute some of those things are you're
able to do with other services but other
services that are out there in the
market today require you to set up a
phone gateway and that's something that
will take you probably a few hours to
set up with everything involved and who
knows how much you need to pay for it
and then you need to connect it to sort
of the relevant bot service and then if
you want to set up a knowledge service
you need to you know set that up
separately and then you need to figure
out you know how many kind of [ __ ]
bytes you need for it because it's
usually like you know server based and
instead of being server lists and then
you need to connect all of these
components and do a lot of coding we
basically did all of that with zero
coding in less than a minute and you
have kind of a full automated bot that
works on the phone so we're very excited
with this and we can't wait to see what
you guys all do with it thank you
so with that let me invite tark hi
everybody I'm Tarek El Khatib
I'm the product manager at Ticketmaster
within the global contact center and
technology department if you don't
already know Ticketmaster sells tickets
a lot of tickets in 2017 Ticketmaster
sold 292 million tickets two percent of
those were over the telephone and
through our contact centers so it's safe
to say we received several million calls
per year so in addition to TV master is
the division of Live Nation
entertainment because of this we receive
a large number of calls of all sorts of
types of events so on top of our common
questions our ticket questions such as I
lost my tickets or how do I print my
tickets we receive a lot of questions
that we general or we categorize as
general questions and many of which of
those are event and venue specific such
as where do I find the will call box
office at Wrigley Field or how big is
the camping area paradisio festival
before I jump in and showing how we use
dialogue flow and knowledge based
connectors integrated into our customer
service I've yard I wanted to go through
and highlight show you two slides that
really highlight the impact that an LLP
like dialog flow could make on to our
sales IVR so over here is the transcript
of Dan calling the ticket master sales
IVR it's a speech enabled I've yard that
was built 10 years ago at that time it
was top of the line and but the
technology then required short phrases
and didn't have any intent or entity
extraction so between Dan talking and
the system understanding it takes 10
attempts for and one missed recognition
for the system to understand that Dan
wants to buy two tickets to see the
chainsmokers in San Francisco on May 5th
now seeing how that would look like with
a NLP like dialog phone this can be
completed in one to two transactions
this is obviously quite an upgrade in
customer
experience or user experience but the
system also has the flexibility to walk
the customer through each prompt if they
still prefer to do so all right now I'm
gonna go ahead and jump into our
integration with our customer service
IVR I'm gonna be showing you two calls
this first call is what categorized as a
common ticket type call a couple of
months back I bought tickets to the
Yankees game which is happening now
today I still haven't received my actual
tickets so the color is calling saying
they haven't received the Yankees
tickets this recording is captured then
encoded and sent into our intent service
our intent service houses a lot of our
complex business rules that thing
connects to our external proxy which
acts as a traffic router between all of
our external services and also
translates all of that API traffic into
a generic API to feed back into the
intent service so once the call reaches
external proxy it's then sent to
dialogue flow right here on the right
agent one that is our main NLP and that
triggers an intent of tickets not
received with the entity of sports team
the Yankees that information is then
sent back through the pipeline to the
external proxy then back to the intent
service we're in the intent service
there's a rule that's triggered based
off of that intent that plays a landmark
prompt let me see if I can help you find
your tickets and then based off of the
entity of the Yankees and the customers
incoming phone number we're able to tell
that this customer had a mobile ticket
order and inform them looks like that
your tickets are available right now
within your mobile within your
Ticketmaster mole lap so now I'm going
to go ahead and show a more event
specific question it's calling to just
add a general questions trying to get an
idea of how big these can't be spaces
would be just the general size at a pear
detail festival so the question was how
big is the area of the camping space a
paradisio festival just like call one
the recording is captured encoded and
then sent to our intent service and the
next
proxy and then it hits that same agent
one our main NLP that's where it
triggers a intent that we labeled as
event and venue specific question and
also yields the entity of paradisio
festival so that information is then
routed back through the pipeline where
it triggers a rule in the intent service
to tell the external proxy to reprocess
the same transcribe text from the first
call and but this time based off of the
entity or paradisio to hit an agent that
is a event specific with the
knowledgebase connector tied to the
paradisio festival fa Q's so there the
answers then retrieved from the FAQ site
goes through back the pipeline and
that's where the customer will hear the
camping area paradisio festival is 25 by
15 feet enough to fit one car in one
tent so I'm gonna go ahead and show you
how this looks like in swagger the
backend so right here I've got the
encoded recording and we'll go ahead and
click try it out and so what's going on
now it's going making that full trip
through the intent service to external
proxy dialogue flow and back and then
here's the result as we see there's no
error that's good
the actual transcript of the call coined
the kana just have a general question
and then the intent is correctly
identified as event venue specific with
the festival name of paradisio fest
Paradiso festival so also below here
you'll also see the additional data that
we appended additional business logic
like landmark and confirmation prompt or
if there's a specific action that needs
to happen based off of this intent type
so the this the second leg of the call
where it actually goes in history
knowledgebase connector is something we
are currently developing so for the
purposes of this demo I'm gonna go ahead
and act as a courier pigeon and show
what that looks like
so
[Music]
so you could see the question is now
returned as a generalist and any camping
site is about 1525 feet enough for a 10
and vehicle and so it can actually
answer these event specific and venue
questions now in our self-service IVR
which previously would need to route to
an agent so to wrap things up here are
key takeaways and lessons learned with a
wide spectrum of potential ents you
really should consider using multiple
agents and knowledge bases this can
really help with tents that are very
related but are still somewhat different
also consider creating an external proxy
with a generic API for product and
feature scalability so we when we built
this external proxy part of my future
roadmap was to also include a sentiment
analyzer but that was before I knew
dialogue or Google would include that in
dialogue flow so but at least have the
ability to now any other additional
advances in AI to easily integrate it
with our system next is conversation
matters put yourself in the users shoes
and anticipate what the next question is
and especially with Ivy ours got to
break the old rigid Ivy are planting
habits those are not conversational so e
these services are only as good as the
effort and the conversation that you
actually put into them finally think big
with AI there's every day we see new
advances in the AI space for example
looking at the phone connectors that was
just announced today in theory we could
utilize those to create a unique IVR for
every major event that we have or even
every major venue so with based on
everyday your everyday business you
should really be evaluating how these
new AI advances really could make a
difference to your business so with that
I'm going to hand it off to Akash for
Marks and Spencers
[Applause]
hello everyone I'm Akash Palma
I'm the Enterprise Architect at Marks &
Spencer anyone here who's never heard of
Marks and Spencer excellent that's like
for you established in 1884 we have 1500
stores and we have 81 thousand employees
three million customers across the world
it's one of the most recognized brand
and it's a very popular British
household name and just to emphasize how
important Marks & Spencer is to its
customers one in three women in the UK
by the browse from M&S and we sell 45 of
them every minute in terms of our
contact centre we take about 15 million
interactions over voice chat and email
and that's handled by 15 advisors and by
our store staff as well so our
leadership team gave us a challenge
where we were asked to understand our
customers better we were asked to
provide more self-service options and we
were also asked to save cost and to
achieve that the first thing we had to
do was to get rid of our rigid DTMF IBRS
and we replace that with a natural
language based solution which would ask
a very open-ended question like how may
we help you with the response back from
the customers was digested into Dalek
flow which would then come back with an
actionable intent this solution it's not
a deep solution going into you know the
depths of dialogue flow which is our
aspiration in the future but it is a
solution which was implemented widely
across our organisation and this
platform would take over 12 million
calls over the next 12 months what this
did was it freed up around hundred
employees who were just busy taking
calls and moving the calls around to
actually not handle those calls and and
beyond the shop floor and actually
worked with the customers who are
walking in and out of our shops as you
can see on the side that's
my boss calls it that stare to our
customer service heaven we are still on
step two so we have a long way to go
quick view of our current solution what
I'll do is I'll try and make a call just
to give you an experience of what it
sounds like just so you know we record
our calls to help with training so that
we can get you to the blue shirts we'd
really like to know what you think today
it's the goal just going to the fluid
and what happened here was I made a call
it went into the Tullio platform which
answered the call and it then invoked
our application which is in our secure
environment the application said you
know how may we help you the customer
said I want to buy some blue shirts it
then used Google speech API to convert
the speech into text that text was
handed back to our application which
then send it across to develop flow
dial-up flow came back with an intent
and within user intent to route the call
to a contact center so that's how it
looks like today
the partnership between Twilio and
dial-up flow is going to make this much
simpler I wish they had this part in
shape six to eight months ago it would
make my life much easier but it's now
here and I think it's a it's a very very
great opportunity so what happens now is
Twilio would integrate directly with
dialogue flow so rather than just coming
back with the utterance or the text it
will actually come back with an intent
and then you know the organization's can
act on that intent very very quickly so
it will a make things faster and B it
will help you know experiment quicker as
well so it's a very very exciting
opportunity
you know this partnership between dialog
flow and
trillium this is our current dashboard
how it looks like let me see if I can
flip across to the live dashboard and
hopefully we'll find the call which I
just made
so basically the dashboard you know it's
a quick view on you know how many calls
we are taking what are our top ten
intends what the date is today my blue
shirts they're there so the top call
that's my calls I want to buy some blue
shirts very clearly you can see calls
come in the utterance was transcribed
very very accurately by Google speech
API went to dialogue flow dollar flow
said it's an order call and then based
on that which said we're going to send
to the sales team so that they can take
the order two key things which I'll take
away or which we have achieved a tool
like dialogue flow was so simple to be
used by the business users so from day
one they were the one who built it
trained the agent and they did it within
days and and you know we achieve now 90%
accuracy on our on our intent the second
benefit which we didn't even realize
we'll get at the start of this journey
was the fact that we could we could now
ask the advisers not to fill in any
reason for contact rather then the the
advisor telling us what they think the
call was all about we actually let the
customer intent do that so it is what
the customer wants and they have said in
their own words and we then use that as
our reason for contact and it's saved
like twenty ten seconds from every call
in HD so we have some big plans with
dialogue flow so now we want to start
going deeper first thing you want to try
and achieve is an end-to-end
conversational order fulfillment journey
so identify the customers integrate to
the back end and also take payments so
that's that's a big aspiration of ours
we also want to use it for any kind of
appointment booking system so we get a
lot of calls around profiting
appointments in our stores so we want to
automate that we want to also go out and
use home devices where we can we have a
dining for 10
pounds offer in M&S which is very very
popular so you know google home Alexa
can be used by the customers to find out
whether we have an offer on going if yes
what's this all about and also some
complex journeys like flower ordering
which is again a very big business for
M&S but a complex journey because they
could be many other many reasons for
which you'll be ordering flowers happy
sad so sentiments gets involved so
that's a journey we want to kind of go
after as well key challenges so one
challenge we had was we had to integrate
you know dialogue flow separately and
now that would go away with the
partnership between dialogue flow and
Twilio so so that's that's that's a step
in the right direction experiment
rapidly but remember there is no price
if you can't productionize it's all
great to have all these tools and
technology but then if we can't
productionize them and send customer
calls through it it's of no use
we need to also be aware of our internal
governance challenges so it took us like
five weeks to get our first MVP but it
took us five months to productionize it
so procurement legal finance you need to
make sure you take them on the journey
from the very start
otherwise you'll be hitting lots of
blockers to have a lean team so I think
my boss Chris McGraw who's in the
audience takes the phrase learn from
your mistakes very very seriously
and it gets upset if you don't make five
mistakes every week so that's what we do
we make mistakes and we learn from our
mistakes and it has worked for us so far
get the right technology partners we had
that in Twilio and in Google Julia was
you know at every step with us in our
initial implementation it helped us
recognize the the potential of this
platform and and I know you know we
thank them for that
you know the accuracy of Google speech
API the accuracy of dial-up flow gave us
confidence to go back to the business
and and and tell them no this is
something which is definitely going to
work it's not you know a question if we
know it's going to work and we went
there with
total confidence partners where we don't
have internal resources if we didn't
have a development team but you've got
to move fast so we partnered with a
company called develop whose CEO Tom
Mullen is in the audience as well so the
key message there is make sure you have
the right team behind you when you set
off on this journey and also know the
technology landscape is changing so fast
you have to make sure that that it's
your architecture your your applications
are open to that new things are coming
in every day and we have to adapt to it
very very quickly as well so just to
conclude you know can dialog flow
virtual agents help contact centers we
at Marks and Spencers are definitely in
the yes camp thank you
I pass it on to Gerard now thanks Akash
[Applause]
hey everyone so let me get a quick show
of hands how many of you have been to a
Home Depot before awesome in case you
weren't aware we are the world's largest
home improvement retailer we have over
400,000 associates and over 2000 stores
across the United States Canada and
Mexico
and we also have one of the world's
largest e-commerce websites so today
what I'm going to what I'm going to do
by the way my name is Jared Mora I'm
from the voice and conversational search
team at Home Depot and we're going to
show you a new feature that's available
in our home depot app Oh
all right so now this is what I'm
showing you here is our beta app and I
actually just got word that this feature
is live on our Android app and it's
going to be live pretty soon on our iOS
app so if you all don't have it already
go ahead download the latest update of
our app and give it a try after the talk
so what we what we developed is a new
version of voice search so now you can
go hit the microphone button I'm looking
for a hammer and it's still work so it
you see dialogue was able to parse out
that what I'm actually looking for is a
hammer we don't actually want to search
for I'm looking for a hammer and then go
and put that into the the search box for
us and in the future we're also going to
use dialogue flow to have a an audio
response confirming to the user that
what we're searching for is actually
what they want to look
cool so how do we do it so we designed a
five layer architecture to enable this
and the first layer is pretty simple
it's just a client so anything that a
customer or associate is going to talk
to the clients then connect to a proxy
ler so if we want to have an optional
layer to you authentication then we add
it there and then the real intelligence
is when we go to the intent layer this
is dialogue flow and it provides the
automatic speech recognition as you saw
intent matching as well as in the future
TTS dialogue flow then goes to our
routing ler and what we we noticed was
if I say I'm looking for a hammer to the
mobile to my mobile phone on the desktop
site on a Google home no matter what I'm
looking for something the way that you
respond to me might be different
depending on what channel I'm talking to
but no matter what it's the same intent
so what we do is we route everything to
a routing there and then route based on
where the client is so if you were
talking to the desktop site we'll get
the response specifically for the
desktop back-end right so in our example
we showed you the page for hammers but
if you're on a Google home then we
couldn't actually show you a page so
we'd have a different response for that
that case we want to be able to handle
that here all right so if I had to
narrow this down into three main things
that you should focus on first of all
and like I just said separate your
action foreign from intents you're
really going to see that intents are
pretty much going to be the same no
matter where you're talking to if you
want to find something you're gonna say
it the same way no matter what you're
talking to but the way you want to be
responded to could change the next one
is definitely design your architecture
for every use case and from from what
you can see in my previous slides our
architecture can be easily expanded to
add more and more clients and that's
something that we wanted to be able to
do so that we weren't stuck a couple
months down the road when we had some
new channel we wanted to add and then we
had to completely reaaargh attacked our
solution in order to support it and then
the less les point is share code between
teams so if you look at our last last
layer the action layer you can we
actually export all of our code it's all
in Google Cloud functions so it's all in
node we export all of our code to an
internal NPM repository and then we can
just have different different
can just import that code add three
lines of code to their channel and then
they can have the exact same experience
in two different channels so that's one
big takeaway and that's going to save
everybody a whole lot of time right so
where are we going next first of all we
want to see what we can do with
knowledge connectors I had a little bit
of time to play around with it myself
and it seemed very very easy and very
quick to set up so we want to see what
we can do to productionize that in the
future and we also want to look into
enabling new intents like where's my
order add to shopping list or finding
products inside of a store and we're
also looking into new channels like the
IVR system and also the Google home
[Music]